you guys as comedians i mean i don't
know what direction we're going here is
that is that
you know with chris rock getting
assaulted on stage by will smith you
brought up will smith
yeah
you know as a comedian is this a concern
of yours that someone coming up and
you're an insult comic family if you
look at your wikipedia not sure if
you've seen it recently bro you're known
as an insult comic no doubt is this
something that you are even more
concerned about these days is what
schmucks in the audience just walking up
you know what i'm concerned with is not
anything physical it's the recording of
sets putting things out out of context
100
uh
you know that's the new scum of the
earth to me these people it's that guy
that got punched by tyson is obviously
now that i didn't even know there was
that second angle of him playing to his
buddy
he's saying film me exactly this yeah
and this is the weird world that we live
in
what what will smith did was will smith
being you know mentally unhealthy
blatantly a victim of whatever jade is
putting yeah well i mean you're talking
about but i'm not afraid of physical
things what what bothers me is people
recording sets and the potential of
putting those out without context the
potential of sending it through an
editing bay and turning down the volume
of laughter in a situation yeah of a
live show tony i mean people could do
that messing with clips
what happened to me the guy that wanted
to get famous from it in an interview
because he did so many interviews yeah
admitted he ended up admitting publicly
that he edited the video and he decided
when he was going to release it which
isn't even completely true because the
chinese government accidentally released
it before he woke up the day that he was
supposed to there's something so talk
about that what happened with that well
i woke up that morning and uh
it was what's weird is i had a crazy
like
crazy like nightmare that woke me up at
like 5 a.m which is a rare thing in
itself and it was weird had my childhood
home in it it was just a weird morning
and i roll over you know how sometimes
you don't really want to look at your
phone you're just making sure nothing
crazy is happening
and sure enough
i was just awake enough to make it from
my text messages from my email to
twitter i'm like i'll check twitter real
quick
and that like minute like a few minutes
before someone's like you
all of these like out of
like not making sense tweets racist you
you racist
up
[ __ ] and i'm like wait what and it's
like career done
dork loser and i'm like what does what
is this what happened
so i end up clicking on one of the
tweets and clicking on the person's
profile right to see what maybe there's
a tweet that they had from minutes
before and it was the video that was
that ended up being released by him the
one that supposedly went viral
hours later with english subtitles but
this was
um the same exact video with chinese
subtitles colored the exact same as the
video that he edited and put out yeah so
he made a version with english subtitles
and chinese subtitles
sent the chinese subtitles to the
chinese whoever news government there's
no difference between the two as we know
yeah and they released it first he must
have slept in uh
maybe drank too much the night before
had a night because he ended up not
posting his thing until 11am meanwhile
it was coming out of china at 5am and i
have screenshots to prove all of that
you know what i mean because i'm
literally like
what is this crazy
chinese video of my set it's a workout
set yeah from last thursday i did an
entire weekend of shows hour-long sets
in other cities that weekend somewhere
else like i'm like why is my workout set
my riffing where i try new things and
take major chances at a comfortable home
club in my home city yeah like why is
this even out there and um
then i realized at 11 am when he posts
this is what happened to me happy asian
heritage month tony hinchcliffe did this
to me
uh and he hashtagged like all of these
asian awareness asian great things what
happened to you the next day like what
happened career-wise did that help you
did that hurt you
at the time at the very very time it
hurt me like immediately because uh i
mean
at the time the every news source is
drag is is
basically telling the wrong a wrong side
of the story and immediately you're like
how do i handle this and there's ways
right yeah so half of your friends are
saying uh whatever you do don't
apologize the other half are like you
have to apologize one half is like you
need to just give an explanation of what
happened i can't believe this guy did
this to you but you're in public
i'm curious what is the publicist i have
a i had a manager a lawyer uh i don't
exactly have a publicist but my lawyer
called me immediately and he's like you
need to talk to i have on the other line
i'm patching you in with the biggest
crisis management uh lawyer
uh professional right now i'm patching
him in i'm like okay i'm gonna hear what
this guy has to say yeah all right and
this [ __ ] guy let me tell you what
being canceled is like this [ __ ] guy
knows what he's doing and probably does
this all the time right he's like i know
what you're going through tony and i'm
going to save you you have to give me 15
000 now and then you'll give me 15 000
tomorrow when you see results and then
if things are still bad you'll give me
another 15. on the third day
this guy just this guy's already at 50
000. this is already the biggest bill
for any employee that is he giving you
any advice thus far like what is he
saying that's what's funny is he's got
nothing necessarily i'm literally like
what what can you do he's like well i
can get out ahead of this i can call the
news sources and make sure that they
don't post i go what if the news sources
don't even know about this yeah are you
going to inform them that this is a
breaking story you had no answer to that
i go what if what i go if i ignore this
completely isn't that the way to do it
and he goes well it's a that's a major
major risk could be the end but these
guys they're used to politicians they're
used to actors or non and actual crimes
mind you right not a comedian making fun
of another comedian at a comedy show
where they're warned beforehand you're
going to hear things that are uh
recording is not allowed all of these
aspects are in play so
these crisis lawyer crazy people are
used to dealing with politicians that
actually [ __ ] up yeah or people that
aren't comedians messing up i mean the
craziest part to me proof that news is
at its lowest point ever is that if you
googled me that day as a journalist
reporting on what you're seeing exactly
what you just said a few minutes ago is
true which is
my wikipedia and i think it's changed
since then i think it now says an
american comedian yeah but just scroll
down further before that literally when
this happened it said
tony hinchcliffe because i remember it
because tony hinchcliffe is an american
insult comedian that blah blah blah blah
blah yeah right yeah it's changed now um
and anybody no you see right there is an
yeah but dude it was originally here's
how crazy this is because i remember it
was originally the first line right
after birthday hinchcliffe is an
american insult comedian because i
always thought it was weird i'm like
american insult comedian what does this
even mean and did you ever think of
yourself as that or just yeah i'm a
comedian bro like a comedian yeah i talk
[ __ ] yeah the only people that bring up
that i'm an insult comedian are the
people that read my wikipedia before i
come in and do a podcast
well look let's
let's address this head on yeah because
i look i used to do stand-up comedy many
years ago vinnie's extended comedian pat
is as great as storyteller as it comes
he just hasn't been on stage yet yeah i
had heard of your name peripherally like
i've followed segura for years and
obviously rogan and i've heard of your
name i mean you know obscure stuff but i
wasn't like all right what does tony
stand for what do you talk about right
and then boom this thing is that hit the
atmosphere what i stand for is exactly
is that type of insanity to where either
you're
either you're loving it or you're
pissed off because you don't know that
i'm doing what i strategically do like
that is my art form
is crazy ass
[ __ ] like to the
brim like not every comedian and what's
crazy is that if it had been
a clean to an extreme we could say brian
regan or jim gaffigan if he did that
yeah that's crazy if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]